-Guys, what a beautiful fall day
it was here in New York City
Wasn't it gorgeous?
It's that time of year
when people look at the puddle
on the subway seat and go from
saying, "I hope that's lemonade"
to "I hope that's cider."
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, I love the fall
in New York City.
There's nothing better tha
watching tourists
in Central Park jump into
a big pile of leaves
and then realize
there's a body underneath.
[ "Law & Order" chime ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
But everyone's
in the fall spirit.
Some people spent the weeken
carving a pumpkin,
while Nancy Pelosi
is trying to impeach one.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
And Trump is still fuming
about the impeachment.
And this weekend
he sent over 70 tweets.
[ Laughter ]
It's so bad,
at one point last night,
Trump's iPhone threw itsel
in the toilet.
"Goodbye, cruel world!"
[ Applause ]
But Trump tweeted he wants
to meet the whistleblower
in person.
However, their identity an
whereabouts are still unknown.
They're probably hidden in
a place no one ever goes.
So most likely,
they're at a Forever 21.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Too soon? Too soon?
-I don't know.
Seems quite hurtful.
-Now, I read that Trump's
chief of staff Mick Mulvaney
could lose his job because
the President is unhappy wit
how he's dealt with the scandal.
If it happens, Mulvaney will try
to get an easier job,
like E.R. surgeon, cliff diver
or coach of the Jets.
You know.
[ Laughter ]
But in the next few days,
top White House aides are gonn
present Trump with an
impeachment-response strategy.
[ Laughter ]
Just in time. Yeah.
That's like the captain of
the "Titanic" going,
"Ah, we should have taken
a left. I'm sorry.
Is that too late?"
Actually, I saw that one of th
President's former advisers says
that he's deeply disturbed b
the Ukraine call.
Trump was furious.
He was like,
"Which former adviser?
John, Steve, Michael, John
Omorosa, Bill,
John, Sean, Mooch?"
It could be one of 50 people
But on the other hand, Trump's
policy adviser Steven Miller
defended Trump and called
the whistleblower a "saboteur.
[ Laughter ]
-Hmm.
-It's the first time
anyone has ever said that
without holding a sword
and twisting their mustache.
[ Laughter ]
"Saboteur!
En garde!"
[ Laughter ]
Right now Congress
is on a two-week break.
And I saw that Nancy Pelos
spoke about the impeachmen
at an Atlantic City casino
See, that's how you know
everything is messed up,
when Donald Trump is makin
statements from Washington
and Nancy Pelosi is speaking
from a casino in Atlantic City
[ Laughter ]
But Democrats now say that
they're gonna vote on
impeachment by the end
of the year.
And this is nice. They've
already hired Ryan Seacres
to host their
Impeachment Rockin' Eve party.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's gonna be great. I'll watch.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Get Elvis Duran. He's here.
-Ten, nine.
-But the impeachment
is already getting ugly.
In fact, Joe Biden's campaig
has asked TV networks
to stop booking Rudy Giuliani.
[ Laughter ]
Trump heard that and was like,
"Finally something
me and Joe agree on.
Please stop.
Rudy, stay in the house."
That's right.
Giuliani appeared
on every talk show
over the weekend.
And he ranted about the Ukrain
scandal, made false allegations,
spoke in run-on sentences,
and contradicted himself
several times.
Giuliani is basically like
if Trump's Twitter account
sprang to life.
He really is.
[ Laughter ]
This is fun. The new Galaxy Fold
was just released.
You see that? It's a table
that folds into a smartphone
Pretty cool actually.
-Ah, big deal.
They came out with it last year.
I have one already.
-That's not possible.
-It's true.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you have it with you?
-Of course.
-Can I see it?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, sure.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Good God.
Higgins, that's a broken iPad.
-No. It's a folded iPad.
[ Laughter ]
-Why is it bloody?
-Because it's sharp.
[ Laughter ]
-Higgins, you should not
be using that.
-It's ridiculous.
This thing is amazing.
[ Electricity zaps ]
Ooh!
I just got a text.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
I'm sorry.
Your phone shocks you
when you get a message?
-Yeah. Doesn't yours?
You need an upgrade.
[ Electricity zaps ]
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
I think I'm --
I got another text.
Oh, I'm getting a call.
[ Electricity zapping ]
-Oh, my God!
-Hello!
-Oh, my gosh. Higgins.
-Higgins, can you take tha
outside, please?
[ Electricity zaps ]
-Oh!
Oh!
-Higgins, stop pressing
the button.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Ow!
-God.
-I just shocked myself!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Finally, I read that employee
are now damaging
workplace robots out of fear
that they'll take over
their jobs,
which explains why today
at the White House,
Trump was seen trying to dro
Mike Pence in the bathtub.